Bodham Pujyami Dhammam Pujyami Sangham Pujyami
Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambudassa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambudassa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambudassa
Bodham Saranam Gacchami Dhammam Saranam Gacchami Sangam Saranam Gacchami Dutyampi Bodham Saranam Gacchami
Duthi Ampi Dhamam Saranam Gacchami Duthi Ampi Sangam Saranam Gacchami Thati Ampi Bodham Saranam Gacchami Thati Ampi Dhamam Saranam Gacchami
Tati Ampi Sangam Saranam Gacchami Panati Pata Veramini Sikapadam Samadhi Ami Adinadana Veramini Sikapadam Samadhi Ami
Ame sumi cacara, veramani sikapadang samadhi amin.
Musa wada, veramani sikapadang samadhi amin.
Sura meraya, majja pamadhatana,
Vairamani Sikapadang Samadhi Ami Iti Piso Bhagavaharang Sama Sambodho Vijasarana Sampanno Sukatolokkawidu Anuttaro Purisadhammasarati
Sattva, Deva, Manusana, Buddha, Bhagavati Ye ca buddha titacca ye ca buddha anagata Pacchupanacca ye buddha aham vandami sabbada Nati me saranam ganyam buddho me saranam varam
He tena satya vajena hotume jaya mangalam.
Kayena vajajitena pamadena mayakatam.
Ajayam kamame vante buri panya tatagatam.
Swakato bhagavata dhammo.
Sanditiko wakaliko Eipasiko opanaiko Pachatangwedi tabo inyuhiti Yechadama atitacha Yechadama anagata Hachupanacha yedama Angwandami sabada
Nāti me sāraṇāṅgānyāṅ Dhammo me sāraṇāṅgvalāṅ E te na sa ca vajena Ho tu me jaya-maṅgalāṅ Hāi na vajacitena Pāma-dena mayā-kathāṅ Hacce aṅkāma-medhamma Saṅdhitika akalika
Supatipanno bhagavattosavakasangho Ujjupatipanno bhagavattosavakasangho Nyayapatipanno bhagavattosavakasangho Samicipatipanno bhagavattosavakasangho
Yadidang chatari puri sa yugani atta puri sapukkala.
E sa vagavato sa vakasangho.
Ahuneyo, ahuneyo, dakineyo, anjali karaneyo.
Anuttarang Punyaketang Lokasati Yecha Sangha Atitha Cha Yecha Sangha Nagata Pachupanasha Ye Sangha Ahangvandami Sabada Nati Me Sarananganyam Sangome Saranangwaram
etena satya vajena hotu me jaya-mangalaṃ kāyena vācajitena pāma-dena-mayaka-taṃ ācāyāṃ kāma-mesaṅgā puṇyā-ketaṃ anuttaraṃ
Ane ka jati sangsarang, Sang gawesang anibisang, Gaha karaka gawesanto, Dukha jati punapunang, Gaha karaka titosi, Punadehang nakahasi,
sabbathepasukabhagahakutam visankatam visankaragatam citam tananam kaya majagam awijapachasankara sankarapachawinyanam
vijñāna pācchā na merupā na merupā pācchā salayatana salayatana pācchā pāso pāsa pācchā vedana vedana pācchā tanhā tanhā pācchā upādana upādana pācchā bhāvo bhāva pācchā jati
Jati pacea jara marana soka Parideva dukkha domina supaya sa sambhavanti Ewa mitasa krivalasa dukkha kandasa samudayo hoti
Yādā hawe pātuvalanti dhamma ātāpino jāyato brahmānasā ātā sakankā vāpāyanti sābhāyato pājanāti sāhetu dhamma āvijāyātve vāsēsā virāgāni roda saṅkārāni rodo
Sankara Nirodha, Vinyana Nirodha Vinyana Nirodha, Nama Rupa Nirodha Nama Rupa Nirodha, Salayatna Nirodha Salayatna Nirodha, Pasa Nirodha Pasa Nirodha, Vedana Nirodha
Vaidana Nirodha Tanna Nirodha Tanna Nirodha Upadana Nirodha Upadana Nirodha Bhava Nirodha Bhava Nirodha Jati Nirodha Jati Nirodha Jala Marana Soka
Parideva dukkha domna suhaya sa niru jhanti He vangitasa ke imalasa dukkha kandasa niru dohoti Yadahave patubha vangti dhamma Atapino jaya to brahma nasa
atasakaṁ kāvapāyānti-sabhāyātu kāyāṁ pācchānaṁ avedi avijjā pācchā saṅkāra saṅkāra pācchā viññānaṁ
Vijnana Pacha Namarupa Namarupa Pacha Salayatana Salayatana Pacha Paso Pasa Pacha Vedana Vedana Pacha Tanha Tanha Pacha Upadana Upadana Pacha Bhavo Bhava Pacha Jati
Jati Pacea Jara Marana Soka Parideva Dukha Domna Supaya Sasambawanti Ewa Mitasa Kevasa Dukha Kandasa Samudayo Hoti
Awijaya Tvevasesa Viraganiroda Sankaranirodo Sankaraniroda Vinyananirodo Vinyananiroda Namarupanirodo Namarupaniroda Salayatananirodo
salayatana nirodha, pasa nirodho pasa nirodha, vedana nirodho vedana nirodha, tanna nirodho tanna nirodha, upadana nirodho upadana nirodha, bhava nirodho
Bhava nirodha jati nirodho Jati nirodha jara marna soka Paideva dukkha domna supaya sa niro janti He vangetasa kevasa dukkha kandasa nirodho hoti
Yadahave patubhavanti dhamma Atapino jayato brahmandasa Vedupayam titati marasena Suryava obasayam antalikan
Heitu Pacheo, Aramana Pacheo, Adipati Pacheo, Anantara Pacheo, Samanantara Pacheo, Sahajata Pacheo, Anyamanya Pacheo, Nisaya Pacheo, Upanisaya Pacheo, Purajata Pacheo,
pachajatapachayo asa-venapachayo kamapachayo vipakapachayo aharapachayo indriyapachayo janapachayo madhgapachayo sampayutapachayo vipayutapachayo atipachayo natipachayo
Vigata Paceo, Avigata Paceo Ti Sabhe Sankara Nityati, Adapanya Yapasati Atani Bindati Dukhe, Esamago Visudhya Sabhe Sankara Dukhati, Adapanya Yapasati
Atani binda ti duke e sama go wisudiya Sabe jamanatati a japanya ya pasati Atani binda ti duke e sama go wisudiya Anicca watasankara upadawaya damino
Upajitvanirujantite zambupasamosuko Drukawatasankara upadawayadamino Upajitvanirujantite zambupasamosuko Anatawatasankara upadawayadamino
Upajitva nirujhanti te sangupa samusukho.
Bringing to mind those whom we know are suffering terminal illness or dying,
Kārāniyāṃ gātā kūsāreṇa Yantāṃ santāṃ padangābhīsāmeca Sākojūcā sujūcā Suvacocā samudu andatīmāni Sāntu sākojā subharocā Apakicocā salaukawuti
Thank you, Lord, for your grace, for your grace, for your grace, for your grace, for your grace, for your grace.
Yekechi panabutati tasa watawarawa anawasesa Digawa ye mahantawa majimarasakanukatula Ditawa ye vadita yechadure wasantiawidure
Butawa Sambaweziwa Sabesata Bawantusukitata Nafaroparangnikubeta Natimanyatakatachinakenchi Biarosanapatikasanya Nanyamanyasadukamichea
Matayataniyangputangayusaykaputanganurake Ewangpi sababutesu Manasambawayeaparimanam Metincha sabalokasmin Manasambawayeaparimanam Udangadocha tiriancha
Asambadanga weyengasapatam.
Titancharan nisinova, sayanova, yavatasa vigatamido.
Etasatingaditeya, brahmamitam vihaganamidamahu.
And our resolution for the day.
īmāyā dhammanu dhamma pāti pāti ādāmāṅ puje nī īmāyā dhammanu dhamma pāti pāti ādāmāṅ puje nī
I maya dhammanu dhamma patipatiya sangham pujih